que ce soit de colombie de toronto de
madagascar s'est fait mon club ça
coïncide aussi avec le
le thématique de réconciliation des
visiteurs de partout dans le monde ont
marché dans les rues de québec à
l'occasion de la visite du pape françois
se tait même de l'opportunité de
visibilité 'un aussi on est très occupé
on est pas mal à pleine capacité comme
destination mais la visibilité mondiale
et on peut pas acheter ça ça vaut des
millions et millions d'allant cette
visibilité mondiale elle est notamment
venu de la part de nombreux médias
internationaux
plus du tiers des 500 journalistes
accrédités pour l'événement viennent de
l'extérieur du canada et malgré tout
cela n'a pas empêché le secteur
touristique de recevoir un peu moins de
visiteurs que prévu encore hier près de
20% les chambres étaient toujours
disponibles il ya peut-être moins de
pèlerins qu'on prévoyait est-ce que
c'est dû peut-être un septième vague il
ya certaines personnes qui ont annulé
leurs réservations en disant que je
dirais trop de circulation de
problématiques ce constat un
restaurateur de la grande halle il est
particulièrement ressentie si je me fie
à mon nom d'achalandage en main la
construction c'est 80 pour sa demande a
dit mission facile la rue a été fermée
plusieurs heures hier et aujourd'hui
pour des questions de sécurité
ce restaurateur a donc reçu moins de
clients c'est tranquille pour nous je
pense que le jeu un plus a compliqué le
travail beaucoup barricadé c'est
totalement comprendra pas besoin pour
nous cette zone de 4,6 on a des
militants employé finalement ne couperez
bleus plus que d'autre chose si les
touristes n'ont pas été aussi nombreux
qu'espéré les dirigeants de destination
québec cité se console et espère que la
venue du souverain pontife sera
bénéfique lors des années à venir ici
jeremic émirats radio canada à québec